how close did you get to having Jack
Nicholson in the judge we had two
meetings with him you know we got we got
we got we were in the conversation he
wanted the script rewritten much more
than we did which was a concern so we
went back in Robert and I sat with him
again and then we just had to realize
like are we going to be more you know we
just felt like defending the material we
were we were concerned with where we
would had to have gone to get jacked
happy and I had Robert in and we were
off to the races and great and basically
Greenland on the movie so we didn't want
to slow down and go back into writing
but they were really fun conversations
and you know jack is a hell of a
storyteller you know it was a different
movie it wasn't wrong or right or wrong
notes it was a little bit different a
little more isolated a little smaller
less of the brother is less of you know
the stuff that was going on but it was a
very interesting film but you know right
after that I remember walking out of
that out of his house with with Robert
and looking at him and going like I
don't know if we can start we've been
working on that script for two years so
I was like I don't know if we can go
back to writing and he was like now
we're not like who's next
I was like what's got to be Bobby Duvall
he's like all right and that's not
happened there's a one two thing it's so
crazy to be why just trying to envision
you're walking out of meeting with Jack
Nicholson and you're like great right
wait yeah and you're like yeah he's just
not going to be in the movie and it's
Jack effing Nicholson you do almost
anything to get him in the movie by the
way he hasn't been in a movie since yeah
exactly so it's it's you know like that
there was a man he's one of my all-time
favorites you know what I mean it was
really it was a hard call but I loved
the movie and Robert loved the movie and
we had a spot and we were gonna miss it
if we if we did his big rewrite as he
wanted to do and we didn't want to do
and some of these you do that and some
movies you don't and you know
I think one of the lovely things about
that film and you know that movies shot
very straight very simple it's a
coverage movie it's all about the
performances I did not try to move the
camera a lot or push things
cinematically I had Yannick so I let him
do it with the lighting but it just was
there is a certain joy to the movie of
like just backing off and watching
people just perform the material on the
script the bill dubuque work an
unbelievable draft of that script